Over the last 12 months, I've built a
ton of projects using Lovable landing
pages, a golf booking platform, and a
ton of personal projects that will never
see the light of day. So, I thought I
would share some of the things that I
wish I knew a bit earlier, some pros,
cons, and little tips and tricks that
will help you get better results while
using Lovable. Now, before we jump into
pros and cons, I thought it might be
useful to see some of the things I've
been able to build in Loveable just to
give you a sense of what is possible.
So, firstly, this is a landing page that
I built in Lovable. It was very quick
and easy to build. There's nothing too
special going on here. You can see it
looks nice and modern. It works. It
fulfills its purpose. Nice and easy. A
little bit more ambitious was this
project. So, this is a golf booking
platform. And this is pretty complex.
We've got a a superb base database
behind the scene. Um there so people can
go and book a tea time. You can sign up
as user. We've got a kind of a user CRM
going on. We've got reporting. We've got
an email marketing platform. And all
this actually works. This triggers
emails to the users via resend. This is
probably the most complex kind of vibe
coding project that I've built. We've
got user authentications. People can
sign up, sign out. So, this I think is
kind of an interesting example. Oh, and
yeah, integrations. We've got a a
functioning Google Calendar and Outlook
calendar integration, which was blew my
mind. So, that to me is kind of I've not
built anything kind of more complex than
this, but this is pretty phenomenal.
when I used to have a team of of
developers that to get to this point I
think would have been kind of easily
sort of three four months of development
work to to get here. So one last example
this was just a fun one that I built for
a friend. This is the Hyrox race
analytics tool. So you pop in your your
race URL and click analyze and then it
shows you some stats about your your
race and how you might train to improve
your uh your race times. So I share
these just kind of give a little bit
context to some of the pros and cons
that I'll now talk about. So firstly the
main pro pro for me with lovable is that
it actually works. You can just in the
sense that when I've tried to build
things with bolt and replet I don't
think they would always get this far.
They sort of get to a point where the
complexity crosses a threshold where it
then becomes very buggy and cumbersome
to try and actually get it working. So
for me, nine times out of 10 with
loveable, you can take an idea and you
can actually get it working in the way
that you imagine it. It also looks
great. I think the reason for these last
two points why it looks good and why it
functions generally pretty well is
because Lovable has quite a tight and
opinionated tech stack. Everything seems
to be built in React and Vite, which has
its limitations
and makes it a poor choice for some
projects, but it also is kind of a set
of guard rails. Whereas with some of the
other VI coding tools, it can build in
any framework, any language, and that
sort of can make it more prone to to
errors and bugs. Love is a little bit
more constrained. But where that sort of
shines is that because it's using
frameworks like Tailwind a lot all the
time for styling, it looks really nice
and it just works and it's not too
buggy. So that's kind of my the main
reason why I I like using lovable. I
find it a lot more stable than replet vo
and just faster to get something good
actually works. A few other things worth
kind of shouting out about. The
superbase integration is super
super smooth. GitHub integration as
well. It just works where I've again
like in bolt I've tried to set up a
super superb base integration and just
chase my tail for kind of a couple of
hours whereas with this one it's
literally a couple of clicks and you've
got a database and it actually works.
GitHub again there's a few bugs. I find
the branch switching um has some issues
on lovable but in general pretty smooth.
I would say something to be mindful of
with um GitHub integration for this kind
of thing is every single every single
chat dialogue that you send is going to
be a commit. So after about a week
building that golf platform I had about
a thousand commits and trying to kind of
then make sense of that or becomes
pretty much impossible. So your choice
whether you'd want it to connect GitHub
early and have this kind of mess of
what's going on or whether you want to
just kind of vibe code it to a point
then put it on something like it and
then work with a developer. Um kind of
up to you depending on on where you land
on that. But that's kind of I think in
terms of the the good it's it's just
pretty functional. So in terms of the
cons I've mentioned one already which is
the limited text stack. Another aspect
of that, particularly if you're building
landing pages, is that lovable has a
bias towards building what's called a
single page web app. Essentially, this
you can think of this as a onepage
website. So the URL doesn't actually
change, but if you go to different
pages, you're still kind of on the same
same URL. Now, there's a lot of good
reasons for doing that, but there's a
pretty massive downside, which is that
that is quite uh a poor choice from a
crawlability and findability
perspective. It's a bit debatable how
important SEO it being discoverable is
now given that more people are shifting
to LLMs. However, I personally want my
website to be quite lean and quite
crawable and indexable, whether that's
by a search engine or an LLM. So, I like
using Lovable for quick landing pages
like this where it's a single page. I'm
not worried. Maybe it's a new project.
I'm not too worried about search at this
point, but I wouldn't necessarily be
comfortable using Lovable for, you know,
a 100page website where I care about
sending traffic to to deep pages. I
think it's yeah, it has more limitations
than than benefits for that. I would
think of lovable as a way of get a
website up and running, but at some
point you will want to shift over to
something like Framer or Web Flow where
you've got a bit more control. Now,
probably the biggest con with lovable is
uh con that it shares with virtually
every vibe coding tool, which is it gets
really buggy after a certain point. So I
think I would almost sort of say like I
find with Bolt and Replet and the other
tools that um maybe it's sort of a
hundred messages or like a week worth of
vibe coding before you hit the wall
where you just spend more time trying to
debug and hit like rebuild try again
than actually making progress with
lovable. It's a little bit maybe it's
two weeks maybe it's 300 messages. It's
a bit arbitrary, but because of those
guardrails, you can build for a lot
longer in lovable without hitting those
roadblocks. But it does get buggy. You
can see from like these GitHub commits
that I get to a point where more of my
messages are about like
um adding login or fixing errors and
resolving issues rather than actually
building functionality. So, this leads
me on to a couple of tips and tricks
that I think will help you get more out
of Lovable. So, the first thing is to
have a really good starting prompt
because as with any project, where you
start is going to set the trajectory for
the entire project. And being one degree
out will mean that a 100 prompts later,
you'll be a mile apart from where you
could be. So getting that initial prompt
as good as you possibly can is going to
make a huge difference in the long run.
The prompt that I use to to start
projects with changes every now and
again. So rather than me sort of share
it here, I will drop it in the
description below and you can use that.
But you can also create your own and
maybe go to something like Claude or GPT
and work with it back and forward to
refine your prompt before you then drop
it into lovable. But I'll share what I
start with. You can then use that for
inspiration if that's useful. related to
that, and this is probably my biggest
tip that I would recommend specifically
with Lovable is refactoring prompts. So,
Lovable don't really promote this, but
they've got this article from earlier in
the year, which is their prompting
bible, and this article is amazing.
They've actually got a newer one now,
but this this one, this is an old one,
and I think it's actually better. So,
they've got all these prompts they
recommend for refactoring. Refactoring,
if you're not aware, is basically like
taking something that has been built
quite messily and tidying it up. And the
reason that's so important is because if
you don't tidy, the code just gets
bloated, crowded, has lots of bugs and
ends up, you know, you have one file
that's got thousands of lines in, and so
you break one line, it breaks the whole
thing. What you want to be doing is
breaking those files and that code up
into lots of little pieces so it's more
modular, more manageable, and then you
don't have as many bugs and the whatever
you're building becomes more stable. So,
we want to do refactoring. It's really,
really, really important. So, these
prompts are really helpful. There's a
really good one that I like, which is
basically like I can't remember which
one it is, but it's basically like
create an a refactoring audit of my
codebase and tell me what things to
refactor in order. I think it might be
this one, number three. Now, rather than
having this saved and constantly copy
and pasting, which I did for months, my
next tip is to install a text expander.
So, you can get these free text expander
um Chrome extensions. And basically what
it means is if you type in the word like
p refactor, prompt refactor, it replaces
it with this prompt. So, I think I've
got it installed. Let me see if I type
in like p refactor. Maybe that's not it.
or like P code review.
Maybe it's not working. But in theory,
you type that in and then it basically
replaces. I think maybe this will work.
Yeah, I got things like that where you
just type it in and it replaces it. So,
this is going to save you a huge amount
of time and just constantly keep your
code refactored and nice and clean. A
few little things inside the lovable
UI that are useful that I embarrassingly
didn't find out until quite long quite
long after using it. So firstly is
knowledge. So in the settings there's
something called knowledge. This is a
really good place to put things like
your coding standards or any information
that you want to basically added to the
context for every message that is kind
of going between you and lovable. So
yeah things like coding style
preferences um documentation style
guides that sort of things. I find style
guides is a really important one because
otherwise you end up with like 50
different shades of green in your app.
So saying like all green needs to be
this hex code. That will just help kind
of keep keep things nice and tidy. So
that's knowledge. The next thing is
using this. So often you will type in
things like I like you know maybe change
this heading title and then it will go
and change a different heading title. So
what you can do is just click this and
then this allows you to select the item
that you want to change and then you
write your prompt. Really simple thing
but just helps kind of with a bit more
precision. um when you're trying to make
changes. And lastly, code. So, they've
made this a bit more obvious now, but I
it took me a while to find it
previously. So, up here, let me choose a
different one. Up here, you can click
this and I'm not on the uh paid account
at the moment. Oh, no. Yeah, we go. So,
you can go in here and you can actually
then just go and make changes directly.
So for things like text changes in
particular or little kind of CSS things
where you don't want to use up your
credits
asking Lovable to make those changes,
you can just go in and directly uh
directly make those changes.
So yeah, if you have any questions about
Lovable or if anything here wasn't
clear, feel free to drop them in the
comments. And yeah, hope that was
helpful. Cheers. Bye.